the smiles are big bright and now
visible along the champs-elysees france
has lifted most of its kovit-19 public
safety measures like vaccine passports
and masking in most circumstances many
in paris enjoying the start to this week
she says it's true that it's more
pleasant to not wear a mask especially
when working to be able to see people's
smiles
the only mask enforcement in france is
on public transport and in health
facilities while the situation in
hospitals is improving case counts are
starting to increase it has one canadian
infectious disease specialist saying
lawmakers need to use targeted public
health restrictions if they're
considering bringing them back and so
it's not insensitive as much as it's
pragmatic to start thinking about the
future where we don't go backwards it's
also very confusing for people to keep
going backwards with policy making dr
neil rau says the country has reached a
point where it's time for canadians to
start living with covet 19. he notes the
next 45 days will be important to reduce
the risks of spreading a new variant
it's time to start living with covid it
doesn't mean we're cavalier and that we
ignore the vulnerable people who can get
the worst outcomes from it we still need
to be careful in health care we need to
be careful with immunocompromised
patients in china that time is now as
the country deals with increased
caseloads of stealth omicron a variant
which has brought the country's largest
outbreaks since the discovery of kova 19
in wuhan
this woman in shanghai says i think the
pandemic this year is worse than the
first year but we aren't really
panicking unlike the first year where
everyone was panicking now no one is
panicking and their attention to
self-protection is quite good shanghai
shut down schools and parks but in the
hardest hit province in northeastern
china some 26 million residents have
been forbidden from leaving their homes
kyle benning
global news